wedding's starting soon how are things
going i was just ordained at
www.internetministrynumeralforcheap.com
but i'm having some trouble with my
speech all we got so far is a poem oh a
poem sounds romantic
marriage is a contract between two
adults of different families
it's a haiku
and a fact
it works on two levels oh it feels a
little impersonal what did the
officiants say when you got married not
much when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was going to
be struck down so speed was of the
essence
and do you kevin yes
and do you yes yes we do
we're married i remarked afterwards that
i wish the officiant had been more
efficient
it was very funny kevin still talks
about it ah maybe i should open with
that zinger
it is amazingly funny
i'm just not sure this is the right
crowd for it
no zinger
no haiku then i have nothing
maybe i should wing it
love
it
sustains you
it's like oatmeal okay
okay
not bad for winging it i lied
it took me two hours to write there
bonjour
wow someone had a good time in paris oh
kevin and i shared a perfect week
together i feel like i'm floating on a
gwa song i wonder why people don't just
break into song more often i've been
asking you for months if i could answer
the phone like
give it a whirl girl
i have zero interest in food if it were
feasible my diet would consist entirely
of flavorless beige smoothies containing
all the nutrients required by the human
animal
so our bank got some new atms huh i
wouldn't know i have switch banks ah no
anyway tomorrow's my
anniversary with kevin i'd like to cook
him an impressive breakfast could you
help
orient me with that process i'd be
honored preparing food for one's lover
is the most intimate gift of all
aside from washing their hair
you know many people think that
scrambled eggs are the easiest food to
make that is incredibly foolish
they are a highly nuanced and
complicated dish okay now go ahead
and pour your eggs right into the pan
nice and slow
oh okay now what do i do oh boy hey when
you hear that sizzle that means the heat
is a little too high on those eggs well
the the higher the heat the faster the
eggs cook the sooner kevin eats am i
incorrect
no you make an excellent point but we
don't want to feed kevin burn garbage
cooking
is about patience
are you completely insane you never salt
can the pan the hand the hand is the
middle man okay
what you did is the culinary equivalent
of
unprotected sex
you know what
you sir are not ready to scramble eggs
hand over your spatula
fine
i only wish in return i could get back
all the time i just wasted on this
futile project
i'm just gonna make kevin plain toast
for breakfast oh
that is low
good morning boyle oh good morning
captain holt after our disagreement
yesterday i went online to read your
culinary vlogs and scoff to my dismay i
actually learned something about how
food tells a story so i made kevin this
it's warm it's a croque monsieur kevin
and i shared one on a rainy afternoon in
paris on our first anniversary
it's one of our most treasured memories
i'm sure it's not up to your standards
but
kevin seemed to enjoy it
so thank you
for your guidance
hmm it's gross huh
no
it's perfect
he's a natural chef
now i know how salieri felt
i'm captain raymond holt welcome
marriage is a contract
but it's much more than that
marriage is love it's
commitment
it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger
it's reconciliation
it's everything it's like oatmeal
it
sustains you
darlene do you take lynn to be your
lawfully wedded husband i do lin do you
take darlene to be your lawfully wedded
wife i do i now pronounce you husband
and wife you may kiss the bride
[Music]
i got to hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony it wasn't difficult i
simply said what i wish had been said
when kevin and i got married oh well
then i never would have heard your
hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing
but all this does make me think i might
enjoy a more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we hold
an honest-to-goodness wedding
nothing too elaborate we're not the
kardashian west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
you guys are fine
here peralta let me give you a tour of
the safe house this is the living room
no stop
you're entering the zone of visibility
someone could see you through the
windows why don't we just close the
blinds at midday it's far too suspicious
blinds will only be closed at night if
you must go into the living room crawl
on your belly observe
seems a little extreme
you're right it's extreme of me to try
to prevent my husband from being shot in
the face i'm overdoing it kevin come in
here take your bullet no fine we'll stay
on our bellies thank you this is one of
several designated areas where you can
stand upright during the day you can
move about freely in the square wow so
we have all this room to work in your
hand can be seen from the living room
window you just killed kevin raymond i
can't hear you kevin you're dead he bled
out in your lap how will you break the
news to me let's see we don't have to do
this ah detective peralta how are things
going with kevin the love of my life
wait why are you here at this late hour
and whose blood is that okay
this is devastating i'm inconsolable and
i've killed myself
cool well i can see this is gonna be a
fun couple of months
hello raymond ready to go to dinner yes
but i have some unfortunate news about
our pie
it was thrown away no are you serious
mm-hmm and i know who did it who you all
bragged about your thanksgiving plans
why
you were over compensating trying to
cover up your dark
secrets but there was one other person
who was also over compensating
you
kevin even better than a plain scone
clean school
i should have known you were lying
there's nothing better than a plain
scone this is ridiculous is it
how the pie was disposed of placed
gently with two hands inside the bin
that's exactly how you always throw away
garbage it is there's only one thing i
still can't figure out why'd you do it
because it's disgusting oh my that pie
is an abomination it has beef suet and
apple seeds in it why it's a walnut pie
if we brought that to my family's house
they would have said something ah i was
trying to protect you why didn't you
just tell me the truth
because i love our annual trips to
saratoga springs the two of us driving
in silence looking at the barren trees
it's perfect hey
i didn't want to lose that
sorry i don't know why we can't still
make the drive next year we just don't
have to buy the pie a trip with no
purpose
raymond
your turn peralta thank you santiago
okay
i know you're mad but before you say
anything yes we screwed up and yes you
warned us and yes i don't know where i'm
going with this but i do know this
i have reached the end of my sentence
oh my god did that work not at all
i can't believe you let a personal
argument derail your investigation i
would characterize it more as a
professional police disagreement i
listened to the tape oh no yeah well
then you know that it was a straight-up
crazy [ __ ] fight look i know we screwed
up the case and i'm sorry but if it's
any consolation i think we also screwed
up our relationship
proud to have a seat i believe this
might help
when kevin and i first started dating he
taught at a small college upstate it was
two hours away by trainer bus but only
30 minutes by car is this another one of
your riddles you rode to work on his
shoulders one set of footprints no
no okay
neither of us owned a car and i didn't
want to buy one because that would mean
admitting that i cared for kevin he had
the same fear and so visits were rare
and i was miserable then one spring day
kevin showed up at my door having
purchased gertie he took the leap and
i'm so grateful that he did i only
regret that i didn't do it first
do you understand
absolutely
100
the train is your old mattress yeah the
car's new mattress i got it kevin is you
um i'm santiago loud and clear 100.
you